spring in the metal Valley it's a place
where nature is at its most beautiful
and most cruel these deer bones are
grisly evidence that this is cougar
country there are around 3,000 Cougars
living in Washington State whether it's
called cougar mountain lion Panther or
puma this majestic animal is a shy but
lethal predator today the Cougar shares
its territory with the communities that
dot the metal valley floor it's an
uneasy relationship especially for
ranchers like Bill White right hard when
the Cougar pulls down in the winter and
starts feeding off the meal deer herd
they don't know the difference between a
horse and a deer it's all food to them
so we have to be real watchful for
Cougars getting on our getting on our
animals they seldom ever do kill off
full-grown or let's or sure cut them up
rub it but Cougars are not just a rural
problem most complaints come from the
urban fringes just 15 miles from Seattle
this is Cougar Mountain the areas where
Cougars once roamed are increasingly
under development as habitat is lost the
weaker members of the species are pushed
toward towns and villages the
bitterbrush covered hillsides of the
Methow Valley hold the secret to the
Cougars population growth with an
abundance of food the local mule deer
population has exploded and when they
migrate below the tree line in winter to
feed the Cougars follow
both fearful and defiant this cougar has
been quartered in a tree but this is its
lucky day the gun contains nothing worse
than a tranquilizer dart and the animal
once caught will be relocated and
released elsewhere it's also release
time for an emaciated female nurse back
to health
cautiously emerging from her cage she
soon on her way back into the forest
sadly her second chance was short-lived
just two weeks later she was shot by a
hunter cornered and facing possible
death these magnificent cats make a sad
and pitiful sight but the authorities
cannot risk ignoring the danger they
pose striking the right balance between
the needs of wild animals and humans has
never been easy for now at least it
appears Cougars will continue to pay the
price